want to know a surprisingly effective
item you can use for a great home
workout
a skateboard this is a mini skateboard
that i bought i think from jdb sports it
was like five or six quid
so it's a cheap item to add to your
workout inventory
or it would work with a full-sized
skateboard if you happen to have one
of those already or you just have the
space and the cash
but it's actually an amazing item you
can use for a pep workout
also good for the core for the legs
there's all sorts of fun things you can
do with it
so if you're looking for a unique and
different workout for your next session
something a bit uh unusual then watch on
i'll show you some cool moves you can
use to
mix things up a little bit
okay so it looks like i'm really
squatting or kneeling for most of this
video
that's fine obviously uh none of these
movements have
official names what would this not be a
particularly
uh official way to work out it's not
something you're gonna find in most
training programs that you'll get
written by a personal trainer
i have seen one other guy on youtube
doing something similar but with a few
differences
but i just uh share some of my ideas
with you guys
the first one is one that i actually saw
this other guy doing on
youtube and it's a little similar to a
rocking press app
what it does is it turns the press up
into a unilateral movement so it's
targeting
one peck more on each each going so you
put one hand
on the floor like so one hand on the
skateboard then just extend that
directly out in front of you
on that side whilst bringing yourself
down
with the arm that's on the ground now
this obviously means you're taking more
weight
for your pec on the left side like a
rocking presser
but at the same time you're also
training the top of the peck and
actually through the length of it there
as well as the shoulder
by extending the arm and taking some of
the weight
on that obviously you can control how
much of the weight you want
on which side go like that
you can also feel the core working very
well stabilizing yourself
obviously you've got to make sure you do
it on both sides and your locking press
up i was
mentioning just in case you haven't seen
it is that one which is another one of
my
favorite pack exercises another one i'm
going to show you
i actually used to do this on a um on
the bottom of a small table
if you saw any of my old videos
perpendicular to yourself put your toes
rather than your hands on the skateboard
put your arms wide apart and again it's
like a rocking presser
except this tank you're going left and
right
and this is kind of the same [ __ ]
press stuff i just showed you
except with a bit more
motion so you're training your pec for
more angles
and at the same time you're further
emphasizing
with one peck that's working plus once
again
yeah abs and obliques
are getting nicely involved there
another one of my favorite
pec exercises is something i think is
just called the
lizard crawl and that's where you
crawl along the ground like a lizard
and that kind of keeps your pecs under
constant tension
and you use your legs in a similar way
unfortunately if you're just trying to
work out your
pecs then having to move your legs like
that as well
just arranging the skateboard back here
can be a little bit fiddly and stand in
the way
so a great alternative is to use the
skateboard
put it pointing forwards put your toes
on it
and you can walk around
to your heart's content
trying to keep your body low
and keeping your pecs under tension
there
and a variation on that to make it a
more explosive and plyometric exercise
meaning it's targeting the
fast twitch muscle fiber giving you more
explosive strength
is to put your feet on the skateboard
and again you're going to move yourself
forwards but this time
little jumps like so and you can
really feel that we're on the
second floor so i won't do that too much
but the people downstairs
might get a little bit annoyed if you've
got a long stretch of
uh patio you can do it all the way down
that
if you don't you can go down the street
and you will strain
people will stare at you but it's still
a cool workout
the best known exercise is the ab roller
which you might be familiar with
it's where you take your
normally echo extra piece of equipment
called an overall
kneel put your hands on it and extend
your body up straight like so
you can really feel that creating those
tears
right across um your abdominals
it's a great way of targeting the bottom
of the abs which people
often forget it's all on exercise but if
you've got a skateboard
then uh the good news is this may need
to buy an extra piece of equipment
i mentioned as well that you could use
this
for training your legs and a great way
to do that
is by doing lunges put one leg on the
skateboard
lunge forwards like so and bring
yourself back
this is better than a regular lunge
because in a regular lunge your legs are
only under tension
when you actually step down into the
lunge
with this you're controlling your legs
and your weight distribution
all the way down all the way down all
the way back up again
meaning that your muscles get more time
and attention
which basically means they're working
out for longer which means more micro
test
which means more growth another way to
isolate one pec
more with the skateboard
just simply to put one hand on it
and press down like that again
remembering to do both sides
those of you who've watched some of my
previous training videos might recognize
this
uh for those of you who didn't watch
them it's pretty self-explanatory it's a
rope
uh so also bought this on ebay for a
couple of quid and it's one of my
favorite pieces of alternative training
equipment
dangle it over your uh pull-up bar and
you can use it for
reverse pull-ups
reverse push-ups which are basically a
type of pull-up touching your lats more
allowing you to do
more repetitions but there's loads of
stuff check out the video
which i believe is still available on
this channel but if you combine it with
your
skateboard then you can do all sorts of
cool movements
because you can move your legs freely
around on the ground so hold on like
this
and then slide your legs out
each time you pull yourself
up
and this way again you're training your
abs
if you're also doing a very unique type
of
pull-up while you're where the angle of
the weight is changing all the time
again you're training yourself in some
unique ways there you go there's just a
few ideas
some things that i do with the uh old
skateboard i don't use all of them
because like i say i live on a second
floor
in my block of flats and the floor's
wooden so i don't want to
risk scratching it however i do use the
press ups at the moment occasionally and
the uh the other ones
and i i find it's a really good way of
getting something a bit different and
interesting when you're
lacking inspiration when you have to
work out from home to have access to the
gym
and your usual heavy weight so uh give
it a go but really the main thing is
just to experiment try different things
so if you uh can come up with any
skateboard exercises i'd love to hear
from you
let me know in the comments or if you
have any other
interesting items that you like to use
for working out actually this
bean bag a lot it's like a bench
my uh bold collapsing bench has been
useless you can use it great for
you know all kinds of presses and peck
flies things like that
but yeah so if you've got any
interesting items around the house that
you like to use
please share i'd be interested to hear
from you and uh yeah hope you enjoyed
this video stay tuned for
more the same as well as more discussion
on brain training
self-improvement and productivity i'm
going to be posting regularly
and hopefully a good variety of things
here to help you to expand your
body and mind through training and
technology as my tagline goes
so thanks for watching stick around if
you enjoyed and i look forward to seeing
you
in the next video bye for now